thank you so much
masked avengers
appreciate you coming thank you thank
you all right i know i know you're very
happy
california's very happy uh newsome beat
the recall that's our big news this week
it was uh
it was a landslide and of course because
this is california it was also a brush
fire two earthquakes
a shark attack and a cult murder but
i kid our state we spent close to 300
million dollars do you know this on this
uh stupid recall how many homeless
people could we have housed for that
money uh
well
in california about three but the point
remains it's the principle
and listen to this we have another
election
in 13 months
and larry elder who was the the main
republican opponent this time he hinted
that he would like to be the republican
candidate in that election and he said
lots of republicans think that's a good
idea
and lots of democrats too
but there are a lot of signs the state
is getting back to normal i saw this guy
today uh homeless uh he was on fire and
getting shot
and and the bystanders kept yelling pull
up your mask
yeah because that's where we are
well the fda today had a lot of big big
hearing there i'm sure we have covert
boosters uh or as dr fauci calls them
the extended warranty
and an executive from pfizer testified
he he thought the boosters were a good
idea and they asked him why and he said
i'd like to buy a boat
now
now this is not good news lions at the
national zoo
have tested positive for covid
they think they might have got them at
the i got it at the pride parade
i uh
[Applause]
i did i did that for you dan
i know
uh and here's the big news in literature
bob woodward
that's a new book full of shocking
revelations about trump's last last days
and about how he would not concede
losing the election wow who could have
predicted that oh yeah me every friday
for four years other than that
the new book
it's uh
one of his one word title books that
woodward has called peril
yes and i don't know how to sum it up
except take everything you thought you
knew about donald trump and continue
thinking it
and
the big revelation in the book is that
in the period after he lost the election
before biden took over on inauguration
day
my birthday no big deal
uh
i'm trying to get people to associate
the two so i every time there's a new
president i get gifts
but boyden's our last president so it
doesn't really matter anyway
uh general mark milley he's the
gen in the head of the joint chiefs of
staff
took precautions to limit trump's
ability to start a war launch a strike
nuclear [ __ ] you know what millie called
his counterpart in china
general lee zhao chang
to assure him look if this nut tries to
nuke you i promise i will stop it i
think the guy was brave i think this is
an act of great patriotism
but
i do
but now general miller he's getting it
from both sides the right doesn't like
that he went behind trump's back and the
left doesn't like that he talked to a
guy named general lee
you